de la lumière pour la sélection de
martinique de football les matinaux on
nous aurons besoin pour battre le
honduras judy a dit long avant dernière
préparation tout est un bonhomme pour la
qualification
l'effectif est au complet la force de
vaincre est là c'est à nous d'aller
chercher une qualification chez nous on
a cette possibilité de la tâche
difficile à trinidad
donc c'est à nous de justement faire le
job et lendu à skolkovo trinidad est il
vraiment se qualifier
mario bocaly reste serein pour ce
dernier match il n'a pas hésité à faire
appel à france agneaux et enough
je vois talentueux anciens du club
franciscain depuis foyalais du collège
tard son âge avancé ne restent pas
l'obstacle
quand on est un guerrier qu'on l'est
jusqu'au bout c'est sur moi je me bats
soit sous mon âge j'aime le foot je suis
footballeur jeu on m'a appelé pour
représenter mon pays je le ferais oui si
on a besoin de moi je mettrais les six
comme audi je veux me défendre
donc voilà donc ça faire moi je suis
prévu d'être avec les murs vous baladera
martinique les pussy hutus qui font
monter le niveau et puis voilà dhr pas
de professionnels dans les buts chauve
et des sages est émis chalets sont
retenus pour les joueurs de shows seront
présents
kévin fortuné samuel camille civile
bambou qui est rivière qui lui sera sa
première sélection en équipe
c'est un grand honneur parce que c'est
le jouet support aci 2000 14 ans je
savais que j'allais revenus pour jouer
avec eux parce que c'est grâce à la
sélection que j'ai pu avoir une vitrine
peu à la france donc je leur dois
beaucoup si ce n'est pas tout donc c'est
un grand plaisir de revenir
cerise sur le gâteau pour les matinaux
la présence de jean d'idole m
fraîchement auréolé de titres de
champion des états unis
je crois que ça c'est important
on y chante inique qui sont les
champions des états unis je pense que
pour nous et puis si ça je crois que je
redis aussi et puis à tous les autres
tous les joueurs locaux qui sont là avec
nous qui a énormément de qualités et qui
se fondent dans son couple ce groupe
avec ses dribbles et les bus au bout
c'est jeudi avait une autre quant à
pierre aliker et matinino battu 1 à 0
par le honduras au match aller sont plus
que frais pour la qualification